So we're here with one of our clients,
and we go show you guys the pool really quick.
There's whole peas right here.
It's supposed to be grass.
It was actually grass already before
they started the project just at,
you know, with the machinery and stuff.
Of course, it got ruined and it needs to be put on again.
So the grass is gonna pull up all the way over here.
And then you're gonna have, you know,
the concrete around the pool, massive pool.
They're gonna be adding a cover.
So they actually already have all the rebar done right here.
Plummin's going in.
So that guys, you know,
starting with the plumbing out with it, the jacuzzi,
and then he's gonna start going around.
Overall, pretty cool pool.
Fucking huge.
If you take a look at it and say.